[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hey Colin
welcome to the show all thank you um I'm
trying to figure out what I need to do I
am 21 years old I am $42,000 in debt and
I just got laid off two weeks ago and
I'm in a bind kind of thing I am
borrowing money from my aunt uncle but I
don't have I don't have any payments
until about 3 weeks from now wow okay um
what's your living situation are you
renting are you living with family uh I
am living with my aunt uncle right now
um they are helping me out um but one of
the rules is with me living with them
I'm getting my GED uh I did drop out of
high school um before I got laid off I
was making a crapload of money for my
age my sister always told me to listen
to y'all she told me to give youall a
call to help me figure it out that's
where most of my debts coming from is
from Cars uh just wasn't spending the
money wisely how much were you
making I was making from 1,800 to 2500 a
week
okay okay um and what kind of work were
you doing uh I was an Oiler I worked on
the road I worked in Kansas New Mexico I
maintained heavy equipment so and are
you are you trying to get back into that
same field or are you looking to do
something else um I'm pretty religious
in my life and I don't necessar what
I've learned over time is money is not
worth it to me and actually I want to
become a firefighter I've always wanted
to be one okay I want to go to school
and I want to try to work on that and I
know uh where I'm at in Texas uh there's
a program that pays for you to become a
firefighter but they only accepted like
a thousand people and it's at the end of
September okay so that's a long ways
trying to figure yeah I'm trying to
figure out a way to manage until then or
trying to get out of debt or figure
something else what's the 42,000 uh
Colin what's like I have a I have a
sports car which is 24,000 of that and
then I have a GMC sper which is the
other is a truck and how much is that it
is I think it's like
19,000 or something like that or 18,000
okay so they're it's all cars literally
two cars yes ma'am and then I have two
other cars also what he how much are
those uh I have a Chevy
it's paid off it's about 12,000 I would
say it's worth and then I have a Honda
Civic but has a blown up motor right now
wow how much could you pay how much
could you sell it if you just like
without a motor with anything just sell
it yeah that's uh that's what I'm
working on I have a buyer for next week
how much how much will you get for it
about 1,800 okay is what he wants to
offer all right that's not going to last
me so long Colin we got to sell up these
cars bu honestly Colin I would just have
a massive car sale I would sell
everything I would sell them all
everything must go I would sell I would
sell all of them what could you get for
the sports car you owe 24 24,000 how
much could you get for it do you think
so the problem with me I love cars and
I'm a car Enthusiast I have modified it
and to a dealership they're offering
12,000 is what I got offered for for the
24,000 okay okay not a dealership did
you Kelly Blue Book
H yeah so Kelly Blue Book came back at
16,000 but with the modifications they
say it's going to be less so I'm stuck
with trying to sell it private party
yeah is what I'm stuck with is this
because you did a bunch of stuff to it
yes it makes a lot more horsepower it's
a very fast
car so I put so I've put about $122,000
into it except for buying it also on
top what about the other car what about
the 19,000 yeah um that's the most
reliable vehicle I have I would say okay
how much could you sell it
for uh I could sell it for around 15 is
what a dealership offered me so if you
sold the Tahoe if you sold the Civic you
could cover whatever you're upside down
truly in either car like even if you
chose to take the hit on the sports car
I'd probably focus on the $19,000 car
the Sierra and I'd get rid of those
three for sure yeah and then you're
going to make
12,000 uh maybe yeah 1,800 from the the
Honda so that's 14,000 that you're going
to make off of selling the other cars so
you can cover some of the difference the
4,000 um with that keep the sports car
and you're going to have 10,000 to put
towards that yeah I mean honestly
without a job right now Colin I just
don't like you sitting with a
$24,000 I don't know if you'll be able
to get a loan for the difference on all
of these either um you know because
usually we get we take a loan out for
the for the difference but if he gets
the 12K from the Tahoe then he can cover
he honestly could cover the upside down
the 4,000 from the Sierra and he'd
probably be able to cover the other
5,000 from the sports car y cuz what are
you paying in payments for the sports
car in the Sierra every month combined I
am paying $450 for the Camaro it's a
Camaro and then uh for my Sierra I pay I
think it's like
$270 look at that that's
$700 that's over $700 a month that
you're getting back that would feel
insurance I'm paying an insurance I'm
paying about 780 a month also for cars
being covered I mean look at that and
then you could take some cash and you
could buy yourself a cash car clear like
you said you're into cars so you know
how to pick a car for $5,000 that's just
going to be your temporary thing until
you get back on your feet and then you
can add money to that and upgrade but
you I mean you got $42,000 of debt it's
all cars and you don't have a
job yeah
and the thing about this is like that
house of cards came down but you get to
build back up stronger and you get to
build build back up on the right footage
so it feels bad right now but it doesn't
have to stay that way and I don't want
you to think that we're like you know
trying to take all your toys away from
you and you know put you in the corner
we just want you to get out of this debt
you're living with your uncle and Aunt
who are nice enough to do that and this
is you going look I made a mistake I'm
going to make it right so I can get up
out of y'all's house so I can stop
borrowing money and next time cuz there
is going to be a next time where you
make great money and you're going to
treat it the right way and you're going
to buy things in cash and you're not
going to go into debt because you know
you will have then known how it feels
for that to cave in on you and you're
never going to do that again yeah cuz
Colin you know you said earlier in the
call that you I think he said something
like I'm a religious person so I'm not
money's not everything to me anymore you
know and that's true but money is
something when you don't have it all and
you got two car payments so like there
is a level of having money in its right
position and I think that's what you
were saying which is very Noble that yes
money is not everything but you do have
to have it as a tool in life so you have
to learn to manage it right so you're
either going to choose to manage it well
and wise so that it doesn't become an
idol in your life or if it's the thing
that you're stressed over and over and
over and over and over every single
month living month to month and stress
it's going to become an idol so as
spirituals we want to make it for it not
to be you actually can choose for it not
to be an idol to have control over it
and I think that's one of the best
things that you can do Colin and I think
that this is a wakeup call I think there
was a part of you that we all have this
like little inner child that kind of
once and once and once I see it when J
crew has a sale or whatever it may be
that you're like it's what I want I want
that I want that yours happens to be
cars and I think Colin there's a level
of maturity here that you're like I'm a
man you're getting your GED which I
think is fabulous and you want a career
that you said is a firefighter and it
doesn't you know you said it's not going
to make a lot but that's okay cuz money
is not a big thing to me well guess what
you get an option to be a fire fighter
and maybe not make as much when you
don't have debt but you don't have that
option to make that kind of money solely
when you have all these car payments too
so like that's the trade-off I want you
to see that living without debt not only
frees you up financially and spiritually
emo we talk about but it frees up your
options like if you have no payments
then you can say yeah I'm going to
choose to be a firefighter make less
than what I made in the oil fields but I
literally can cuz I don't have bills so
like I have the freedom to choose that
which is beautiful and that's what
you're stting to see Colin is that it
gives you options like it gives you the
ability to make decisions with your life
you know I was talking Colin to this
young couple when I first started
speaking and they had close to $180,000
in student loan debt combined they just
got married out of college they went to
two Christian universities they wanted
to be missionaries whoa and you can't
I'm like I don't know I don't know what
to tell you you have bills to pay so
Colin this is the best thing for you I'm
so excited for you sell these cars
become debt free get a side hustle work
till September to be able to be go be a
firefighter and do what you want to do
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life